So, using the stripe group for a long segment avoids first of all the small-ray
pitfall. So for instance here, we might decide for certain log segments x, y,
and z the stripe group is this. And for another set of log segments, say p,
q, and r the stripe group is this. And for another set of log
segments, L, M, and N, the stripe group
is this. So we're subsetting the servers into these
stripe groups, and what that allows is parallel client
activities. If the log segments X,Y, and Z, belong
to a particular client. And if the log
segments P, Q, and R, belong to, a different
client, and L, M, and N, belong to, a
different client then you can see that the client
activity corresponding to this, this particular stripe group
can go on and parallel with this. And similarly
this activity can go on and parallel with
other stripe groups that exist in the system and
so on. And so it increases the availability
of the server in saying that not all the
servers has to be working on the same client
request. Different subset of servers are working on different
client requests and that results in higher throughput
for overall client processing. And also. When it
comes to cleaning the logs, remember that I
mentioned earlier that every once in a while, you
have to clean the logs because the logs
may have been overwritten by new rights to
files on a particular client machine, in which
case there are logs that Have to be recycled.
And if you don't recycle them, you're filling up
the discs with junk. And therefore, every once in a
while, we have to go and clean up the
log. And so efficient log cleaning is again facilitated by
the fact that you have different stripe groups, so
you can assign different. Cleaning service for different stripe groups
that increases the parallelism in the management of all
the things that need to be done in a distributed
file system. An increased availability also means
that you can survive multiple server failures.
So let's say that these two disks fail for some reason. You can still
serve the clients who are being served
by this particular strip group. That's the
idea of sub-setting the server group for
striping so that you increase the availability and
allow incremental satisfaction of the user community in spite of
failures that may be happening in the system as a whole.